the heart of the pilot complex is hidden
in a container one can still safely open
it up and examine its workings up close
but when the system powers up it
produces extremely high pressure at
temperatures of up to a thousand degrees
Celsius that's when it becomes a real
steam boiler and the beautiful part is
its quiet low noise nothing steaming or
puffing it's a technical facility that
produces highly purified fuel without
people outside noticing much the people
behind this technology want nothing less
than to produce gasoline using just co2
water and electricity other companies
already do that but Sunfire has a new
process using high temperatures pressure
and steam
let's perform a special part of this
electrolysis is that we've raised its
effectiveness level to 90 percent so
that we now need far less electricity to
produce the same amount of hydrogen it's
a more efficient process and that's
decisive if in the next step fuel is to
be produced on an industrial scale from
hydrogen and the greenhouse gas co2
corporate partners have already been
found
they include fuel company total and
carmaker
OD the latter is willing to invest to
soon be able to offer its customers
climate-friendly car fuel from
facilities like these it certainly
doesn't make economic sense with this
equipment at this point in time you have
to build bigger complexes and a major
factor is how cheaply one can buy
electricity for the process mind Colvin
couldn't the pilot system in Dresden is
already large but nowhere near the
dimensions it would need to produce fuel
in the real world even with low
electricity prices renewable fuel costs
five times more than that made from
crude oil still Sunfire is confident it
will be selling commercial complexes by
the end of this decade supervisors and
typically these kinds of facilities work
well with refineries you have to imagine
combining a conventional refinery with a
renewable refinery from Sunfire and then
produce both fossil fuel and renewable
fuel which you can then combine and put
into the infrastructure submission come
on in the infrastructure point
no definite sites have been selected on
which to build the first facilities but
the company's confidence is evident in
its new industrial building where it
plans to construct the future complexes
individual components
you